okay yes
thank the Lord okay hey baby what's
going on Bravo thank you so much for
coming so here's what I want to make
sure y'all understand right now right
off the top I called you to report a
crime that I don't have nothing to do
with okay oh this is a first I'm not
involved in the crime I didn't
perpetrate the crime I didn't do
anything okay I was yes ma'am yes we can
I was madam Oh I was walking down the
street ok and I was indeed I'm not gonna
lie I'm a vagabond a bit I'm a little
bit of a bag about I was looking for
shelter I found this vehicle the window
was open and I climbed it I looked in
the trunk and there's something in the
truck that I think may be of interest to
you so I made that I called immediately
what's in the trunk and there's a head
in the trunk is a head 23 year-old male
head hypothetically okay what would the
percussions be hypothetically I just
hate you Jerome why did you - but why
did you mother we're not real playing
anymore playing real-life why did you
say Jerome that's my cousin's name they
just come to me right now is your cousin
living or alive he's alive with the Lord
alive with the Lord get your ass in the
car
hypothetically speaking you're about to
get your salad tossed in prison oh okay
well thank God is hypothetical
[Music]
[Applause]